you actually did Mighty Ducks years
before Dawson's Creek and that is that
hard like I just think whenever I was a
kid I did not want to stand out and like
when you're an actor in such a huge
movie like that and then you go back to
school was it cool or did people pick on
you
um it was a little bit of both okay so
one I'm Canadian so
obviously oh no we take hockey really
really no I know but people are nice
there okay there's no mean kids right I
feel like I hate to break it to you
don't bring don't burst that bubble for
us we are all nice all the time okay
thank you thank you um yeah high school
you know it had its challenges
definitely and going away you know first
off you disappear for a couple months
and nobody knows why you're gone and
then you come back and nobody cares why
you were gone and then the movie comes
out and they're like so you think you're
special now and that's what I mean and
the kids can be so hard kids are tough
but on the flip side of it you know for
me I think acting can be a difficult
Journey for a lot of young people yeah
but for me it gave me a place to focus
and to have something that grown-ups
would respect me for you know if I went
and I worked hard and I and I showed up
and knew my stuff I could actually get
get respect from grown-ups which you
definitely don't in high school yeah you
know you're the problem so it actually
for me was a really healthy release in
place to focus even if not all of my
fellow students enjoyed my success yeah
Engineers they're jealous
um so wait do you remember how you found
out like when you got the role that's a
huge role for a kid so the in um in
Vancouver Public elementary school
there's these things called mini schools
so the mini schools like one is called
cloutwood Trek that takes you get to be
outside anyway I went to the art school
because I wanted to be an actor yeah so
one of the things that you have to do at
the mini schools because you're in
public school is raise money to pay for
anything that you want so every year you
do these phone drives so I was like in
the utility closet at the school and my
mom called through the central
switchboard to be like hey guess what
you got movie as I'm in the middle of
being like hi would you like to donate
five dollars to Ideal mini from
so that's the Glamorous space that my
career started I love
[Music]
it
[Applause]
I'm going
[Music]